you know many many years ago I was
trying to get a book deal and I'd put on
a little talk about how to lose weight
because my book was all about that and I
hadn't sold hardly any tickets so I
canceled it and the same day my agent
called me went oh my gosh I've got six
different Publishers who want to come to
your talk I'm like well I just can't
this one put it back on quick because
they're all coming and it was that
weekend and I think she called me on a
Thursday night so on the Friday I rang
all my friends everyone said come to
this talk it's completely free and and I
got lots of people to come because I
knew that six major publishing houses
were coming to this talk and she told me
one of them was definitely going to give
me a deal if not all of them so I only
had Friday and on Friday I could have
spent ages planning the tour but you
know I didn't I actually made a mood
board I thought that's a good thing so
on Friday night I had an old picture and
I took it out of the frame and I started
to stick things in it and I wrote
Marissa Pierre gets a great book deal
like I cut out the time they're selling
this and I stuck it in and wrote on it
my book and make me so excited about my
talk and the next day I went off and I
did the talk and lo and behold at the
end somebody came up to me and she said
oh my God I love that talk and you
should come in on Monday and we're going
to offer you a book deal straight away
and we'd really love you not to meet the
other five Publishers we want you so
that was very exciting and in fact I did
end up signing with them and it all was
wonderful but I know it was that mood
board that helped me because it took my
mind to where I wanted to be it made me
Focus only on success of course the mood
board doesn't say things like I might
not make it the mood board has success
so let's imagine you want to be a
therapist
that's what your vision is or a
photographer maybe you want to be a chef
I want you to imagine you've got a mood
board and you fill it up with pictures
if you want to be a chef pictures of
great food reviews from restaurants and
of course you're going to cross out the
name of the chef and write your name in
and said in black marker pen so find
lots of reviews and put your name in and
then right all over the mood board too
let's say your name is Alexandra
Richardson you're going to put Alex
Richardson instead of that chef and
you're going to put lots of reviews and
let's say you've found
uh the top 10 best restaurants and
you're going to call your restaurant the
fox and so you cross that and you put
the fox Alex Richardson's restaurant the
fox and just keep looking at that and
you write all over your mood but all the
things that work for you people love
this restaurant the best restaurant in
wherever you live in the world the food
here is amazing and then you look at
lots of interviews with chefs and you
imagine your interview and you put it up
there you can even mock one up that's
what
printers have also mock up an interview
mock up everything and look at that mood
board mock up all the things that you're
going to cook they're going to give you
pleasure mock up the cookery book you're
going to write mock up so much stuff you
know a couple of years ago I was asked
to work with probably the angriest kid
I've ever worked with in my life and
when we started to work he said you know
no one loves me I have no love in my
life and I realized that his anger was
actually incredible pain but I talked to
him
and I asked him what he was good at he
said nothing so asked him what he loved
he said cooking so we talked about that
a bit and he's ended up being a
phenomenally successful Chef he's got a
great girlfriend he went to work for
other chefs he's now got his own
restaurant his life has changed
dramatically because I found one thing
that he loved and focused on his purpose
and the reason he was here and he loved
cooking so much that I knew straight
away that that's what he was meant to do
and now he's doing it his life has
changed 360 Degrees mood boards have
been proven over and over again to
stimulate your brain to excite your
imagination to keep your focus on where
you want to go you need to create an
environment of Excellence Excellence
most people's environments are not
excellent the people around you the the
videos that you watch the things that
are on your wall the voices that are in
your head you have these moments that
are bold that are courageous that make
you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today you don't want to stay stuck
you want to be in a different place
could actually be physically moving but
a different place in terms of your
finances in terms of your purpose in
terms of how much you're giving and
caring and sharing and the life you want
to build you want to be somewhere
totally different like today this is not
acceptable anymore I accept that this is
where I am right now but where I end up
is not going to be the same spot as
where I am right now right if that's
your commitment the biggest shift that
will help you get from where you are now
to where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and that the more intense it becomes the
more you're actually living it the
faster you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the people that you look up
to the the whoever of the world like I
want to be the next whoever perfect that
person the more you hang around with
them the more it's going to rub off on
you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now here and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos I like to see things I
need to be visual if that's you then you
need to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it can
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot of espresso to help you but if it's
not my channel it's some other channel
one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or the the one
video because that one video on repeat
is gonna lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch it again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good you
watch it the next day and the feeling's
gone so you can't just read the same
book over and over watch the same video
over and over and over again the key is
to find a consistent source so if you
love this channel you love this video
I'm making other videos just like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more
a sense of hope and purpose that you can
do it too you'll start to think more
like him so be careful who you pick and
maybe you don't like Elon Musk maybe you
like Kanye West or Oprah Winfrey or
whoever but the more you're around that
person the more you will start to think
like them so you want to put that as
part of your daily routine that every
day because yesterday was a different
day you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today is a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you can have the best day of all
time you wake up the next day and it's
gone so how do you keep the consistency
the routine
tell yourself I'm going to watch a video
even when I don't want to even when I
feel low energy even when write all the
excuses we come up with I'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state I need to get into because I want
to follow I want to follow my dreams I
don't want to be stuck here anymore
tied to that is then subscribe to the
channels
that make you feel that way so do an
audit
of all of the channels you follow on
YouTube of all the people you follow on
Instagram anywhere you're spending time
on social
do an audit of who makes you actually
feel more bold
and who makes you just waste time
or who makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them
and then the people who make you feel
better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we are designing
our routines around this that I'm going
to watch a video every day with my
heroes so that they pull me forward
right we're putting it into our calendar
the second part of it is I'm also going
to subscribe to channels and people that
inspire me so that when I happen to be
on the platforms I'm feeding myself with
things that inspire me and lift me up
instead of waste my time or put me down
okay so that habit that environment
really really matters the second part of
environment to create our environment of
Excellence right is the physical
environment so this office inspires me
this office this was all with intent the
people on the wall behind me we got
Steve Jobs AP giannini my parents
Howard Schultz Kanye West the trophies
uh you know the YouTube stuff the the
getting
my hands wrong here this side you know
the art the art that people drew my book
uh my neck brace from when I broke my
neck like all even the colors on the
wall all of this it inspires me this
inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself
I see Steve Jobs staring me down I see
my parents staring me down it's like a
reminder of what I want to do because I
wake up and I and I don't have you know
the the most energy I don't feel super
bold and like let's go take on the day
right I don't have that as soon as I
wake up
but we manufacture it through the habits
and routines but also the actual
physical environment and the beauty
about this is you only have to set it up
once you know I set this up once and
then I walk in and every day I'm being
hit with these messages and reminders of
the person that I want to be so whether
that's a mood board you put up for
yourself where there's people that
inspire you you have to look at the
thing it inspires you to want to push
you a little harder it inspires you to
want to believe in yourself and more it
inspires you to want to go off and take
some kind of action today the physical
environment matters a lot and you can
control that so think about think about
your office think about your bedroom
think about your car think about where
you're spending significant time and how
much of that has actually been done with
intent
how much of your physical environment
has been created with intent to make you
believe in yourself more
it matters a lot and then the third
thing really quick is the actual your
outfit the clothes that you wear how you
show up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work that might sound really
dumb or cheesy but you know what it
works for me I am a superhero going to
work I'm not fighting crime I'm fighting
lack of belief I want people to believe
in themselves more and I'm going to work
when I see there was a green arrow show
I used to watch
and when they were in their their base
in their Lair they always put their
outfits on a mannequin right so they're
when they're off fighting crime they're
in their uniforms but then when they
come back to their base they're in
normal clothes but they put their
outfits on a mannequin so I went and got
myself a mannequin it's it's just you
can't see it but it's just sitting here
off camera I got a mannequin and it's
got my hoodie on it as a reminder that
I'm a superhero going to work every day
and again that might sound really cheesy
or dumb or corny but I like it it works
for me and putting this on every day
instead of just showing up in my pajamas
I just I work from home you know we've
got 30 something people on the team I I
don't see my team physically that often
most people work from home I could just
show up every day in my pajamas
by putting this on
reminds me that I'm a superhero with a
mission
whether you want to adopt that or not is
up to you but but how you present
yourself for yourself not just for the
camera I'm not putting this on just for
the camera I'm putting this on because
it's what I put on this is for me
I could make a video of my pajamas
that's fine but I'm making this for me I
wear this for me what do you need to do
for you not just because there's some
expectations when your expectations of
yourself become higher than what you
think other people's expectations are
for you that's when the game starts to
change when I'm wearing something just
because of how I think you guys will
perceive me or or some speech I'm doing
or some meeting
I'm I'm only living up to that person's
standard to what I think their standards
are and said no I'm doing this for me I
wear this for me I show up like this
even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this because I'm a
superhero going to work and it's my
reminder
this is how you start to create an
environment of Excellence guys your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment is keeping you stuck
and if you don't want to be stuck
anymore if you want to change your
circumstances if you don't want to be in
the same spot you are right now one year
from today you have to create an
environment of Excellence
how do we do that number one we start
feeding our mind with Excellence from
the videos and podcasts and books from
people who Inspire Us number two we
change our physical environment so that
you walk into a room you walk into your
car you walk into your bedroom or office
or wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a superhero
going to work every day because you are
on a mission
you've got a great heart you've got tons
of ideas
I see it over and over and over and over
and over again
so much potential
and just stuck
just stuck
because there's a lack of momentum that
stems from having a really poor
environment
if you can just change with intention
that I am going to create an environment
of Excellence for myself that inspires
me and pushes me forward to step into
the person I want to believe that I can
be
you can do that every day
entire life will change
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
first thing that people who are
incredibly successful do is they do what
they hate they are fully prepared to do
what they hate to get to where they want
to be and and people who fail they will
give up their dream before they do what
they hate to do people who are very
successful they never ever ever wait for
motivation they do it
because when you do it you become
motivated a great writer won't go well I
just wait till I'm really motivated to
start writing this book no they get up
at four in the morning they don't want
to and they start to write and then of
course they become motivated you wake up
in the morning and you go you're not
going to go yay it's 5am I'm putting on
my running shoes and going for a walk up
Laurel Canyon
of course you're not going to do that
you're going to wake up and go God I
really hate working out but Marissa said
successful people do what they hate to
get to where they want to be of course
the wonderful thing is that when you do
what you hate first enough times it
starts to become natural like I've got
to do my taxes I'll do that first thing
I've got to confront someone
um I'll do it first and so I still to
this day wake up and think oh I don't
really want to do that so I'm going to
do it first because what I do want is to
belong to that group of very very
successful people so I know what the
membership is and everything I don't
want to do something I think I don't
want to do it but what I do want is to
belong to that group so I'm doing it
first and it's it's a great way of
thinking because it starts to move you
around wanting to do it for all the
right reasons many many years ago I'm I
met someone who wanted to be a rock star
that was his ambition actually
particularly wanted to be a drummer and
he was a very young married man with two
children to support
and he was going for a lot of auditions
and of course all the auditions take
place during the day and every time he
had a job they wouldn't let him take
time off so he decided he would have to
work nights in order to audition during
the day and the only job he could get
was a job he hated he was a taxi driver
and he hated it but he did it but he
just wasn't making enough money so he
thought okay I'll have to work in
McDonald's I get more money I can work
nights I'm free to audition and about a
month before he'd applied to work at
McDonald's he'd been for an audition to
be a drama in a band he didn't know who
the band was and the day he was due to
start working at McDonald's which he
absolutely hated even the thought of he
got a call to go you know that band you
auditioned for it was actually simple
minds and now you're the drama in Simple
Minds that he never worked in McDonald's
or drove a cab again for the rest of his
life but when he told people that story
they'd all go oh I would never work in
McDonald's oh my God I'd never degrade
Myself by driving a cab around London
and I'm like don't you think you're
missing the point
his ability to do what he hated is what
made him a rock star because he had to
have his days free to rehearse and
audition but if he had your mindset I'd
never do that he would never be a
multi-millionaire rock star it was
because he was fully prepared to do what
he hated to swallow his pride to keep
his vision in mind I want to be a rock
star I must be free for auditions
how can I do that well I have to work as
a cab driver and in a fast food
restaurant which I hate but I'm going to
do it because it's going to take me to
my goal and it did but the people who
laughed him and said I wouldn't do that
none of them are Rockstar you mentioned
something about
leaning into the feelings until you're
no longer need to kill them or before
they go away feel the feeling and it no
longer requires to be felt why do we why
should we do that so give an example of
it okay so let's imagine you you and
your ex-wife are not getting on and you
have a feeling of Rage about the fact
that she's trying to get your kid to
call a new guy daddy and she's blocking
you out and you feel so angry I think I
mustn't feel angry you know she's doing
it for the interest of my kid or and so
I just drink the anger and I drink the
anger and you see with the feeling it's
the most real thing you have a feeling
is like a little kid and a class going
notice me I'm over here and if you don't
they get more and more out of control
and so when you don't acknowledge your
feelings they regroup and they regroup
until they become outrage rage coming
out and then suddenly they go a bit
crazy in the car park of a store or the
line of a store because the mind says
I've got all this rage wants to come out
so I just cut in to the Line Take It Out
On them and it's so ineffective because
I have something I call
Triple A which is be aware of your
feeling most people have no idea what
they feel they got I shouldn't feel
jealous I shouldn't feel envious I
shouldn't be furious with this kid who's
keeping me up all night so they're not
aware of it they certainly can't accept
and they never get too articulate if you
can say you know my wife's a good person
but actually I'm furious with what she's
doing it really hurts my feelings that's
why group therapy in places like a a the
good thing is you get to say sometimes I
could quite cheerfully
um hurt my wife I'm not going to but I
feel like oh yeah I feel like that too
because when you can express your
feeling it goes away it goes away
immediately but when you educate it yeah
even to yourself so if your
mother-in-law is the absolute somehow
and you can't say by the way Dorothy you
are the most horrible mother-in-law in
the world
but you just go and shut yourself in the
bathroom turn on the Taps flutter and
say Dorothy is a really unpleasant
mother-in-law
I feel so much better because you're not
saying it to them it's like feelings are
like gas they're in or they're out and
they hurt much more when you keep them
in and you want to let them out maybe it
has to be not obviously right in the
middle of a meeting but when you keep
stuffing it causes you pain you have to
understand a bit more of psychology
because humans are hardwired to recreate
what they know we like what's familiar
even if that's very even if it's very
bad if I've never had money and I win
the lottery I'm going to get rid of it
or if I've never had love and you love
me I'm going to reject you because it's
so unfamiliar if I've had a dad who
calls me an idiot and worthless guess
what kind of guy I like that's it
because when I meet them I go oh I feel
like I've known this guy my whole life
we just clicked and they think oh my God
it's because he's my dad but now I've
been sleeping with them for six months I
don't know what to do with that now
because we are wired to like what is
familiar and to resist what's unfamiliar
and that's what kept us alive when we
lived in water you didn't go I'm a bit
bored with this group I think I'll go
outside the water City and find another
tribe because they might have killed you
so we have this wiring that says run
towards what's familiar and run away
from what's unfamiliar
but the very good news is you can make
anything familiar and the most important
thing to make familiar is praising
yourself that's if you could just do
that that in itself would change how so
your entire life how do you praise
yourself
well you get out in the morning and go
I'm a good person I have a skill I have
a town I have something to offer the
world I'm here for a reason you look in
the mirror and go oh there you are
you're a good person you've got a good
heart you know the most important way to
answer that question is this
what did you always want your dad to
tell you even if you never had a dad if
you had a dad a good dad what would he
have said
what would your mama said what would a
nice teacher have said to you and it
would be something like this I'm proud
of you
you're a good son I'm so glad I'm your
dad how lucky I got to have you and a
teacher would say you're such a smart
kid what a joy it is to teach you
because you're smart and we all want to
hear the same stuff I love you I'm proud
of you you're interesting you're great
coming nobody needs to hear I'm the best
dentist in Beverly Hills because that
doesn't work it's emotions and many of
my clients
their mother might be dead but they're
still trying to get her to approve of
them dads living in another country but
they're still working to make him like
them
and you know the most important thing is
you like you your beliefs affect your
world you believe certainly affect your
biochemistry I've had women of 58 say
could you make me pregnant I go I know
it's too late why did you wait 30 years
but the mind will follow your
instructions and it's very important to
give yourself the right instruction of
course they're our limits you can't tell
yourself you're going to be an astronaut
and people said I want to be a
millionaire like what are you going to
do to be a millionaire you can't go
wrong with sit at home and that's the
problem with the secret
attract Millions to you what are you
going to do for these ones I want to be
have a six-pack you do need to go to the
gym I want to have great health well
stop eating pizza and eat better food
but once you get the mind to want it
it's actually easy but when people say
to me I want to be a millionaire then we
tell them well any goal of significance
requires you to learn something new but
then they have a fear of learning and
and of course you're right then when
people come in and go I want this you
have to look at the blocks the number
one block is the fear of rejection
if I make it I might get rejected if I
find love they might leave if I make all
that money people won't like me anymore
so you've got to smash out of the
ballpark the fear of rejection you've
got to smash out the second belief that
says it's all easy I remember Luther
Vandross saying you know people say I'm
an overnight success I sang Jingles for
KFC for 12 years
it was a long overnight so you do have
to also have that desire I mean for me
you know I speak in public I write books
always aware that somebody's going to
hate your book I don't like it I'm like
oh that's okay they can't reject me they
might reject my book most people happen
to love them but to get anywhere in life
you have to get over the fear of
rejection
because people think they're going to
die from rejection but they really don't
people come in and they describe you
know I really want to be successful but
I'd love to be healthier but I want to
find love but I can't get pregnant
because
and the first thing we do is investigate
like a good detective a detective will
lay out pictures and go what's going on
here and they make sense of it and very
much the same some people come to me
going I've got unexplained infertility
what is that it went well there's a clue
in the in the in the description it is
unexplained nobody knows your husband's
got crack sperm that swims straight and
plenty of it you've got great eggs great
Fallopian tubes perfect womb but you
can't get pregnant because the The
Unexplained is here
and many people when they're younger
will say this if I got pregnant my dad
would kill me oh my God if I got
pregnant with the end of the world and I
remember when I was 17 thinking I was
pregnant oh my God no disaster oh my God
my dad will be so upset devastated when
I wasn't I went on thank you God yes Joy
but you see the Mind listens to
everything you say the mind is always
switched on and it records everything
and it never forgets so
in a moment of absolute Terror or fear
or pain or anxiety there's something
called an imprint it goes in so a child
whose mother says that cat will scratch
you and give you blood poisoning or that
dog's gonna bite you or that's a
dangerous person or you know I went to a
little kid who had a terrible fear of
monsters under the bed turned out his
dad used to say you'll get run over if
you do that you'll kill yourself if you
do that you'll drown if you do that
turned out his dad was the monster
because he was scaring him all the time
so you get a young person can be an
adult and you get an imprint and what we
do is investigate where where did this
imprint happen and when we've got the
imprint which is very easy you can ask
questions to get the imprint you can
listen to the client's Story the one who
said my mum used to cry when I brought
up food and so happy when I ate or you
can use hypnosis and go back like that
and the reason I love hypnosis so much
is you go to the imprint you know people
come to see me within five minutes they
have the imprint there's no oh how does
that make you feel and how do you feel
now and let's talk more about that and
come back next Wednesday at four and
we'll keep this going because studies
now say that's that's actually the worst
thing you can do because you just keep
the story alive so we do the
investigation we find the imprint
and then we we interpret it what does
that mean why do you think you know your
dad telling all these stories would now
leave you to have this monster under
your bed why do you think
15 being terrified of being pregnant
could possibly mean that today you've
got an expendability and they work it
out they go yeah now you say that if I
look at those scenes and look at this
scene it all makes sense and then you
interrupt the belief massively and then
you install a brand new belief you know
you're getting pregnant like a high
school kid on their first day you're
super fertile you've got crack grade ax
your husband's got the SAS of sperm and
it's gonna Collide so you bring in the
very powerful language and you are going
to make a grade A B because of course
because I want to be pregnant I'm like
no you don't you want to make a baby
that you carry to full term I've been
pregnant eight times
you want a perfect bouncing healthy baby
so it's another example of not telling
your mind what you want so the
combination of the imprint the
investigate the interpret the interrupt
and the install
is so powerfully transformational when
you focus on the worst possible outcome
you actually feel as if you are in that
worst possible outcome the only way to
overcome a fear is instead of focusing
on the worst possible outcome to focus
on the best possible outcome I'm driving
it's foggy it's dark it's icy I might
skid off the road and kill myself or I'm
driving very carefully I'm driving very
slowly I'm driving very cautiously
because I'm going to be safe and I'm
going to get home see that's the
difference you just have to give
yourself different beliefs the thing
with fear always is you have two choices
rationalize where you feel so terrible
or tool yourself out when I was on the
beach with my daughter and there was a
big dog and it was quite a scary dog and
she didn't like this dog and I said to
you know darling when you don't like a
dog you get very scared and the dog
doesn't like it either and he gets
scared so when you see a scary dog turn
your back to it don't look at it because
when you look at it you're challenging
it and that's hard to do to turn your
back on a dog but if you turn your back
it's not a challenge and she understood
that and I was always teaching her when
you have a fear you have a choice oh my
God that dog's going to bite me attack
me hurt me or I'm going to talk myself
I'm going to turn away I'm going to
breathe they're going to be really calm
and that dogs is going to go on its way
and it's the same with everything in
life to do with fear rationalize why you
feel so fearful or
took yourself out of it are we fine this
is okay everything's gonna work out
perfectly I'm okay all of these fears
hold you back and they don't have to
because every fear you go through
teaches you something you see if you go
to a fun phone go to those loop the loop
rides you can scream in Terror or you
can scream in excitement and the fact
that people put themselves through those
rights means that at some level we quite
like fear it challenges us to do more it
challenges us to grow more so don't fear
fear remember the only fear to fear is
fear itself I find that even with cancer
if you have that belief I'm going to
trial this stuff but it won't work and
you know it's I'm riddled with it and
there's no hope and they start to read
all these terrible diagnoses I mean in
England you are not allowed to say to
them and you've got 10 months to live
because that's what happens they turn
into the 10 months you cannot diagnose
what do they tell them they just say you
know we're going to do this and this and
you may not survive this but you could
and and in the same way that if you're
having surgery and they go look this is
a complete mess in here there's just no
way even in surgery your subconscious is
hearing what's going on around you and
there are many people who come out of a
coma who said you know I heard
everything the hearing is the last thing
to go and so if you make a choice to
talk to yourself better
you can bounce back you might as well
use your mind as much as you possibly
can
to be well we tell ourselves the story
we play the only part we've ever known
and then that part becomes our own and
we don't know how to separate it and so
we'll come in with their story and they
go well you know I nearly I was a
newborn baby and my mum told me that I
was only like two pounds I nearly died
they had to drop milk I mean with a
dropper and I remember my mum telling me
she used to cry every time I got weighed
or if she fed me when I threw up they
would get so upset because I could die
like okay and now you're 600 pounds
because you keep telling yourself that
story
and people tell themselves the story
until it validates why you know my dad
didn't love me he left before I was born
he never came to see me but he had
another kid that you treat like Jesus
bought him everything game boys clothes
so if my dad didn't love me I'm not
lovable and you have to go but that was
then your dad was an idiot that's
nothing to do with whether you can find
love or not
the clients tell themselves this story
and they don't understand that at any
age you can go well I I think it's time
for a new story and so my job is to
first of all find out where where you
know they come and go I don't know why I
do this I guess I'm just messed up
I don't know why I can't speak but I've
always been that way going no no baby
looks away when you look at them in the
house or no baby goes don't look at me
I'm having a bad hair day we're all born
with so much confidence you have four
children they never go now I can't get a
banana in my mouth I I can't get to
grips with this walking reaching they're
they're wired to go for something but a
lot of damage is done very early and and
I see that all the time really silly
things like people coming and going you
know I can't ask for money and then our
TT has what I call interruptions or
after they've gone back
they have to then say but that's not me
because and that can't be me because and
that won't be me
ever again and what that does is it
starts to change the neurons it's
actually called
neuroplasticity it starts to change the
way the brain is wired they stop
thinking the way they thought as a child
and put into place different beliefs and
then they're forever changed and it's
amazing to see it in action you always
have a choice
your mind talks to your body all the
time that's its job and your job
is to tell your mind what you want I
want perfect health
I don't do illness I do Wellness
everything I do is perfect you know I
was at a conference recently someone
around them oh my God I'm so glad I
listened to your audio because you know
I have four hours of sleep and I tell my
mind I'm having eight and I thought I
should do that I'm teaching people this
I forgot I can do that too tell my mind
I've had eight hours sleep tell my mind
I feel amazing tell my mind when I'm
working out my body loves this my
muscles love this I can do a bit more
rather than go oh it all aches and I
hate doing this and I could be a home
watching TV
so just to be very clear your mind's job
is to do what you tell it and your job
should you choose to accept is to tell
it great things amazing things
I'm not aging I'm saging I'm and I'm
embodying Wellness I have perfect
balance you can choose
not only does the mind tell the body
what to do it also interrupts the
signals coming back from the body I've
got this crippling thumping headache and
become what I've got a little niggle in
my head but I'm really too busy to
notice it I'm in agony no you've just
had a little shot that's not Agony this
commute is hell no hell is not having a
car or any gas and looking at people or
taking three buses to do your commute
being in this store is torture no
when you go to Africa and you see they
don't have any stores and the ones they
do have no food and you'll never again
standing rafts and go this is a
nightmare it's hell grocery shopping if
you have money in your wallet to buy
food with people that love you that is
so far beyond hell but people use these
words that's killing me it's a disaster
it's a nightmare and also whenever
anyone does anything wrong we go what's
wrong with you we should say what
happened to you what happened to you and
they'll go well you know my mom always
said she didn't want a girl voice you
wanted a girl and I've been brought up
give an example I had a city Trader as a
client who really had problems trading
and his boss said you know he's the best
Trader but he's so nervous and when I
worked with him he was when he was a kid
his parents had two girls and then him
and he would smash his tongue good
towels are going to go what's wrong with
you look at your sisters just combing
their doll's hair and they're so good
and why are you so aggressive and before
you can't go well because I have
something called testosterone and they
don't and I'm designed to run and jump
and hunt and fish and I gotta learn what
to do with aggression smashing my cars
together is good for me he didn't a
four-year-old doesn't have anything
because they live in the world yeah they
just live in a world of feeling not
logic and he said I never realized just
spent my whole life thinking something's
wrong with me because my parents would
say everything comes what's wrong with
you look how neat this is they don't get
Peas on the floor when they eat and he
said I heard it every day until I formed
to believe something's wrong with her he
didn't date women because he thought
well I should be like one but I want to
be like a man and that session totally
turned him around he said it was like
he's someone had sprayed it with
pheromones because he went out that
night when we were attaching themselves
like a magnet but he just got rid of the
feeling of something's wrong with me
because most people do walk around
getting something's wrong with me I'm
just majorly messed up
and you can't heal no one understands me
no one gets you yeah and I don't
understand me and if I don't understand
me how can you and why should I even be
here yeah because you can't hear what
you can't understand and so all the
treating the symptom is like putting a
Band-Aid on an infection it doesn't when
you understand it you can totally change
your perception of what it is because
events actually don't affect you but the
meaning you attaches and does the story
We Tell ourselves the story we have a
great fear of rejection which is not
surprising because when we're born we
have two drivers find connection
avoid rejection after all if a mother
rejects a child if a lion rejects the
cob he's not going to be adopted it will
die yeah or it just starves to death and
so we know innately that our Survival on
the planet is linked to not being
rejected
and not that long ago you would have
died from rejection you know in in a
thousand years ago when they banished
you outside the walls of the city or you
marooned a difficult sailor or you cast
someone out of the community but you
pretty much died there was nothing out
there but Purgatory so we have a wiring
that says rejection will kill me
and that's why you have the fear but
when you can dialogue with no it feels
like it will kill me it can't kill me
because no girl can reject me unless I
give her my permission right give them
my power you can't reject me unless I
agree with everything I don't like you
because you've got short hair I don't
like your shirt I don't like you because
you're white not white all sure glass is
not
but when you say you can't reject me I'm
I can't be rejected because the only
person you can reject me is me you can
talk to girls realizing even if they say
no you're not my type I'm with someone
no thanks or even ooh not no they can
only reject if you let that in and we
look at someone like James Corden who's
certainly not gorgeous but women love
him because he's funny so funny and you
know we like warm people you know the
the packaging is all very nice those
will have a great packaging a great
wrapper and it'll but they're unhappy
and so our greatest fear is to be
rejected but the truth is in 2018 you
could live in this apartment have Amazon
deliver your groceries never see a soul
and you probably live until you're 106.
yeah wouldn't I advise it but we don't
die of rejection anymore but we still
feel like we will and all schools should
be teaching kids you cannot be rejected
you can ask for a pay rise you can ask
for crowdfunding you can go to someone
go here's my idea you can write a book
speak in public because with a lot of
actors who say I'm so scared of
rejection I'm like well how are you
going to be an actor then
you and I write books for everyone who
loves it there's going to be the odd
person because I hate this book and I
hate that writer too but we don't let it
in we have to laugh about it when you
give a YouTube talk I mean I've got one
of my talks about like three million
views and there's a few and they're
going I hate to stuck up English
um snob but they don't know me because
that's not me at all but I don't go my
God I can never write another book I can
I'm okay because I don't let it in
because the only opinion that matters is
my opinion I know I'm not a stuck-up
English snob so that can't hurt me in
powerful language you can never say you
can fall you're going to mess that up
you're going to ruin everything
that's just not going to work out you
have to say the opposite okay I've only
got 10 minutes to prepare my speech I
only need 10 minutes I've only got 10
minutes to get there that's exactly how
much time I need and if I'm late I
wasn't supposed to be there on time I
have a belief now when I get to a party
late it's because it wasn't I wasn't
meant to get there early I no longer go
my God I'm so late this is going to be
terrible in fact I was recently going in
a cab across town to get a train to work
with a football team and we got stuck in
traffic and so I was playing a game I
thought oh my God I'm going to miss the
train this is terrible I'm going to ruin
my reputation the team are going to be
so upset and I felt really sick and then
I started to say the trains run every 20
minutes it doesn't matter what's 20
minutes my material is so great they
have lots of time off well they're
finished
practicing at three o'clock and and it
was fine so all the way there I was
playing a game
and I actually got the Train on time but
they really wouldn't have minded but I
could have ruined my day made myself
panicky and sweaty but going oh my God I
haven't got enough time and now it's all
ruined and it's never ruined you can
come back from anything and then I
worked with a client who had cancer and
had to go into this MRI scanner and
every time I saw him I can't I can't do
it I can't get in that scanner and I
wanted I said well I feel like I'm in my
coffin I feel like it's a premonition of
my death and I get in this scanner I
think well I've got cancer and I'm going
to die and what I said well I freak out
I press the button I have to come out
and they keep saying look you've got to
go on I can't even be in there for two
seconds which is not true I can't do it
for even a second he probably was in
there for a few minutes I said look the
words you say to yourself in that
scanner this is a premonition of my
death I feel like I'm in a coffin I feel
like I'm suffocating and I can't do it
that's a blueprint and your mind doesn't
like those words so how about these
words how about saying I'm in my bed at
home and I'm just so chilled and I could
lie here for hours I'm chilled I'm
relaxed I'm blissed out you must use
words that make a picture you can't go
oh I'm okay really I'm quite good I'm
not bad this is okay because when I say
the words okay not bad where's the
picture
there's no pictures what I call fluff
when you say I'm chilled I'm blissed out
I'm ecstatic I'm just lying here and I
could do this for hours it's just so
cool the Mind goes you're right and when
you go I'm in a coffin and I'm
suffocating the Mind goes you're right
see here's a great thing you can choose
any words you like you can go well we're
all going to be negative and this house
is going to be positive that's your
choice you know what you can't choose
what you do to yourself when you say I'm
an idiot I'm a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] I've
got rocks for brains everything goes
wrong who would ever like me I've got
cellular I'm a single parent I've got no
chance blah blah blah I didn't go to
college so I couldn't possibly do what
you do I got kicked out of college by
the way so you can definitely do what I
do and it was the best thing that ever
happened to me I can look at my life and
say being fired being dumped and being
kicked out of college thank you God for
putting that in up to me because it
changed my life it was the best thing
rejection has been one of the best
things that ever happened to me being
the least favorite kid if I could have
my life again I'd go back and be the
least favorite kid because I thought I'm
going to show my parents that I'm
something and if I was the favorite I
wouldn't have done that I would have had
a totally different life here's some
things I want to start doing today right
now that will build your self-esteem
super fast the number one thing
is to praise yourself there is nothing
nothing nothing that will build your
self-esteem like praise but your Praises
if you have a Shoppers and says oh you
look really great in the outfit yeah it
suits you you must buy it they have an
agenda if your boss says you're amazing
at your job but I need to give you work
today over the weekend they have an
agenda
someone dating you might have an agenda
and your mind knows that when when you
say I'm great at my job I'm smart I'm
kind I'm nice people like me there is no
agenda unfortunately when you go and
rubbish at my job I'm boring I always
mess up and I have no friends your mind
lets that into because your mind doesn't
really care if what you say is right or
wrong good or bad healthy or unhealthy
let me prove that to you I want you to
put your hand in front of your face like
that I want you to close your eyes I
want you to imagine you have a big fat
juicy lemon and I want you to breathe in
that wonderful lemon smell and just
squeeze it a bit and feel that wonderful
lemon texture because nothing quite
smells like a lemon so still really
believing you have half a lemon in your
hand
open your mouth
shove that lemon in there cram that half
a lemon into your mouth and start
chewing and sucking and biting and
swallowing the flesh keep sucking all
that lemon flesh into your mouth bite it
chew it suck out the juice
and you will notice what is happening is
your body is responding to a thought as
if it's a fact
your body is responding to the image and
thought of eating a lemon as if you are
actually eating a lemon and it's making
a saliva because thoughts are things
and every thought you have
a physical reaction in your body and an
emotional response to when you think I
don't have friends I can't talk to
people I can't take things back to a
store I can't ask for special treatment
I don't know how to talk to people then
your mind accepts that as a fact just
like the lemon but when you say
oh I can talk to anyone I'm an
interesting person I'm warm and friendly
people like me and I can make eye
contact I'm good at my job I can ask
someone out on a date I can tell the
person I'm involved with what I need
your mind accepts that too and someone
recently said they keep a lemon on their
desk now and look at it every day I'm
sure they change it every month because
that lemon reminds them every day that
they are responsible for what they think
and feel and you know responsibility
that word means an ability to respond
so I want you to start to praise
yourself I want you to wake up in the
morning the first thing you go is I like
myself you do know don't you that people
who are critical
have so much criticism reserve for
themselves they actively dislike
themselves and you're actually showing
me and the entire office that you really
don't like yourself by critiquing me
yeah by creating You're just showing me
you're critical people always have
criticism reserved for themselves they
are full of self-criticism but they
reflect it out and Superior people and
happy people always praise and people
who feel inadequate always criticize
because criticize Withers you and praise
builds you up and if you can use those
five techniques thanks for sharing could
you repeat that are you trying to hurt
my feelings won't work I'm not letting
it in since we're sharing did you know
what is running your critical Behavior
you don't let it in and being able to
not let in criticism that too will
change your life it it makes you
bulletproof you can't stop moving mean
and having a horrible day and we now
have trolling which is becoming an
epidemic so it's actually worse our kids
used to get bullied at school and go
home to a sanction another bullet online
now they're bullied online on the phone
and it's it never ends and they feel
really attacked and see when you find
trolls they're usually really miserable
and unhappy but they love the power
because they have no power they live on
their own or with their mum they have no
life I mean we had a terrible situation
in England where somebody was trolling
this person whose child would have been
kidnapped and when they exposed her she
killed herself oh man which was a
terrible thing for her but obviously her
sense of shame that she was outed and to
kill herself but she must have felt
terrible I felt so sorry for her but she
was very in her trolling but that's a
really unhappy person she needed a lot
of help but when you can teach people to
come back from criticism without
fighting or going well I hate you too or
you're a little shut up or crying when
you can just teach them look
I'm not letting it it's like if I try to
give you a gift you go and I don't need
that gift I'm holding the gift I can't
give you something if you don't take it
I can't serve papers on you unless you
accept them I can't serve a volume to
you unless you volley it back so when
you learn that people can try and give
you anything but if you don't accept it
you haven't let it in and if you don't
let it in you can't hurt you it just
hurts the person who's left holding it
how do you help people establish meaning
behind when I wrote a book called I'm
enough and we have a program enough and
what that does is it takes you the
process of where does this come from
you're not born with this belief how did
you get it and when they discover how
they got it they're able to give it up
one of my first ever clients was this
beautiful woman very hard to believe
which is I can never make a relationship
last
and it sounds so silly but she said that
her dad you say to every day you'll
never ever find anyone that loves you
like me nobody could love you like me
you'll never find the kind of love that
I have and
he programmed when you label someone you
limit them so now she's got an imprint
I'm never going to find a love like this
love and guess what she never found love
like that and all you have to do as a
parent should say I love you because
you're lovable
and all your life you'll find love like
this love because you're worth it so
it's little tiny adjustments that have
the most profound effect on people and
it's never too late to say I'm enough I
can find love and now if you give
someone the power to make you feel good
you give them the power to make you feel
bad and if you do it to yourself
you feel so much better it makes you
slightly bulletproof you still need
other people we all need other people
but the dialoguing with yourself and
starting with I'm enough
I picked that because I found all my
clients addicts binges bulimics
saboteurs hoarders compulsive compulsive
shoplifters they all went back to the
same thing I'm not enough
I need more and if you feel enough
you start to feel equal see most of us
feel unequal you're better than me
because you've got money or you're more
attractive than me
but no dog or cat says oh you're better
than me because you're a pedigree a baby
doesn't know that another baby's wearing
designer clothes and they're not they
they have no concept of that so really
what I'm enough is doing is reactivating
re-manifesting and regenerating what you
were born with an ability to say I'm
enough in my experience people who try
to be perfect are the unhappiest people
in the world and they're almost always
the loneliest too when you try to be
perfect you have entered a race that you
can't win you can't even complete it
there is no Finishing Line the Finishing
Line keeps moving so when you're in a
race to be thinner happier richer more
successful you can't complete that race
you can't win it instead of thinking oh
I'm reaching my goals you feel intense
dissatisfaction here's the truth the way
you feel about everything is under the
pictures you make in your head and the
words you say to yourself and guess what
is so great you can change those
pictures anytime you can change those
words every thought you think
every word you say becomes a blueprint
that your mind body and psyche use
everything at their disposal to make
real thoughts are things what you speak
and think and say without realizing your
mind is working so hard to make that
your reality even if it's super negative
you know I see parents all the time who
say things like I'll be happy when my
kids sleeps through the night I'd be
happy with my kids out of diapers I'll
be happy when my kid is walking feeding
themselves going to school and they
spend their whole child's life looking
at the next bit to be happy when you
should be thinking wow I wish every
stage took three times as long you waste
your amazing life wishing it away for
the next bit because happiness is not a
destination you arrive at it's the
journey you're on it's an inside job do
not Farm out I'll be happy when because
there is no terminal to get to good
happiness happiness is a journey are on
now perfectionists come in all shapes
and sizes and they're often very good at
hiding that inner drive to be perfect
there's one thing that drives them all
an inner belief that says I'm not enough
I'm less than if I'm less than and I can
come across as perfect I'll be more than
you know my neighbors always say to me
wow you have so many famous clients are
they damaged by Fame I'm like no
actually no damaged people are attracted
to fame they have a belief I'm so
damaged but if I'm famous Rich gorgeous
amazing I'll be perfect did you see what
happens when damaged people try to be
perfect it actually damages them more
you don't need to be perfect you don't
need to be Flawless you don't need to be
infallible you just need to be enough
and when you let the fact in that you
are enough instead of trying so hard to
be perfect which you can never achieve
when you let in being enough changes
your life so let it in that you're
enough right now because that's the
truth about you people think the brain
is really complicated it's not it's
actually quite simple you only need to
know three things about your brain to
always get what you want and the first
thing is your brain does exactly what it
thinks you want it to do because it
listens to everything you say so when
you say things like oh God you know I
got dumped it was so painful I never
want to go through that again or your
mind can pick up is you you don't want
to be in a relationship again when
people have a miscarriage and go I could
never never go through that again I'd
rather die than go through that again
your mind is picking up all right well
that's that's a statement that's
actually a command to me to make sure
you never go through miscarriage again
and that that's how you get unexplained
infertility
which is something else I've been
working on a lot recently because the
mind listens stories is we will go oh I
went on this fly I thought it was going
to die and do it like that I'm never
getting a player it's this plane lands I
will never ever get on a plane again and
of course it lands I go it was just
turbulence but next time they go to the
airport of a massive panic attack
because your mind's like hang on a
minute you said I never want to fly
again
and so if you haven't got what you want
it's because you're giving your mind
very confusing messages your mind's
number one job is to listen to what you
say to interact on it the second job is
to move you towards pleasure and away
from Pain and it will always always do
more to avoid pain so let's imagine
you've gone for an interview you've done
it as a public speech thing like me and
you've stood up you've got a uh uh and
you say oh my God I'm never doing this
again and you'd have a terrible
presentation and one of my clients who
had for Sony was saying that she had to
stand up just say to Sony this is a new
band from Camden and she stood up and
went this is a new band from
and they're called
uh I I couldn't do it I just was the
simplest thing and my boss had to take
over and I was explaining to her that
when you do that and go oh my God I
don't want to do it I don't want to do
this again your mind is now going to
make sure you don't do it again so the
next time you go to speak it will give
you a panic attack it'll make you ill
and if you say to yourself oh my God I'd
love a week off in bed or I'm dreading
next Wednesday your mind is so in tune
with you your week off in bed you wake
up with the flu and everyone's like
there you go how cool am I there's your
week in bed you don't want to go to that
speech I've woken you up with diarrhea
so now you can't go
that's what the Mind does when I was
giving my first ever presentation about
my first ever book I woke up with the
most excruciating migrant of her hand
while before I thought wow I must have
been saying to myself so I don't want to
do this because I've got this migraine
and I actually went and did it and I
didn't have the migraine until I stepped
back off the stage again and I realized
that I was communicating very badly with
myself so you must never say nervous say
excited because your mind listens so
those three things are your mind does
what it really thinks you want to do if
you're very very specific and say I want
this and this I want to be a great
speaker I want to deliver things I want
to be fantastic at sales I want to be
able to look the online sell them things
and come across as really authentic your
mind will understand and if you make
those pictures really good
and pleasant you'll move towards them
when there is a battle between logic and
emotion emotion always always always
wins how many of you have gone to a
really high building and in closed
building like the top story of a hotel
or the CN Tower in Toronto and look down
and thought oh wow I feel really scared
my logic my nose that I'm safe that the
glass is that thick that I can't fall
but the emotion that's making my stomach
Lurch is winning so when you have a
battle between emotion and logic emotion
always always always wins here's
something you all know we can all ring
our friend and go I'm a bit bored a bit
lonely can I hang out or I'm a bit bored
let's go to the movie you would never
ring someone you've just met and go I'm
bored and lonely will you come and hang
out with me let's go to the movie
because the emotion that you might be
reject will overrule the logic that says
this person may be the person for me so
if you're having a battle between
yourself here's a great one I know I
shouldn't eat cake that's the logic but
the emotion is oh the cake feels so good
in this creamy sugary stuff reminds me
of being a baby when all my needs were
met by having creamy sugary stuff so in
a battle doing emotion and logic logic
will never win emotion will always win
and you can make that Win For You by
making it a better emotion so here's how
to do it here's an emotion I'm scared to
ask for a pay rise in case my boss
laughs me out of the office make it a
stronger emotion if I go to my boss and
show them what I've done how valuable I
am that won't happen here's an emotion I
really want to ask that person on a date
I'm not good enough
change the emotion I'm wonderful I'm
amazing what could I get from asking
someone on a date that says yes so much
and if they say no I'm only exactly
where I was before except I've been
brave I've done something courageous
I've taken action even if it doesn't
work out I've lost nothing but I've
gained courage so when you're having a
battle doing logic and emotion emotion
always wins logic never wins that's why
you could stand on the windowsill of
your apartment if it was on the ground
floor but you would never stand on the
Windows there same size if it was a
hundred stories out because the emotion
that you may fall to be the logic that
says I can do this when it's a few feet
off the ground why can't I do it up here
because emotion
overalls logic you can make your life
phenomenal extraordinary and wonderful
by by always using emotion to defeat
emotion every baby on the world is worn
loaded with self-esteem no baby when
they're being pushed down the street in
their stroller goes oh don't look at me
I'm having a hat bad hair day or I've
just been sick on my little Romper suit
or I got really fat legs babies first
experiments on the planet is being
looked at when you're born the doctor
the nurse the Midwife look at you family
come to visit you you get your picture
taken people show you off and babies
don't avert their eyes when you take
their picture
when I used to push my little girl down
the street looking her pram go oh my God
she's so gorgeous she never looked away
she kicked her little legs she gave a
big gummy smile because she knew that
she was gorgeous too and if you ever
doubt that children like attention
go to a park go to a swimming pool in
your hair every chugging mummy mummy
look at me on the swing Daddy watch me
on the slide mummy mummy watch me jump
in the wood Watch Me swim watch me jump
because children have this belief that
I'm worthy of attention and I like it
and I can ask for it and I'll get it
then you have to ask well where does
that go well it goes very fast you know
if I said to my little girl look to sing
mummy a song she would sing if I said 14
sing me a song she'd roll her eyes and
go my God you're so embarrassing and
walk out of the room because at a very
early age we require a fear of being
judges what is called performance
anxiety what if I sing and someone
laughs at me what if I read in class and
I get it wrong what if I stand up to
speak and I don't know what to say
performance and anxiety can be so
intense that it makes us stop performing
but people who perform really well like
themselves well I'll see what happens
and I'll sing our dance I like I mean
some people can't even dance a party in
case everyone is looking at them
and judging them badly some of my
clients won't even go to yoga in case
they can't hold the poses like everyone
else and believe me we're all so busy
worrying about ourselves we don't have
time to look at you and
comment on your yoga position or how
you're dancing at a party and we kind of
like people who don't care who just let
go and have a good time
so the thing you need to have phenomenal
confidence really are two things stop
judging yourself
and be nice to yourself here's my advice
to you expect amazing things then if
what is expected tends to be realized
expect the best expect love and success
and an amazing life because you know
what it will probably be realized really
fast if you expect if you want another
amazing Marissa peer video check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there